hey everybody welcome to the great big
story YouTube channel this is Dave
this is Jillian let's get to the show
today we're going to watch for great big
stories and the first one features a
piece of fabric that's 1,500 feet long
and wrapped around one head
let's meet Bubba Singh and his giant
turban Despard abba gentleman logged on
'god paper / vm picasa kilos audible ah
ah ah hey hey go Meera demolish a scope
on Palomita de Malaga
yep I'm about dancing mahakal Santos's
Anto bada badda bodda me Vedanta malama
total savant a Maharaja min wanna mean
parka channel chickadee
[Music]
Varda rova my apprentices the Bellagio
bachata CEO menudo Bellagio news
allergies article develop disease Natali
material part Aruba remember your event
a year ago Camila da ba da da la da da
da da da da da maneuver our Baba Yaga
motika if the cookie Nicky nada para
Java parque da da da da da da da da
porto photo photo American Legion Giga
Europe and Republicans ever forgotten
Iveco saviola men oh boy Bassanio when
the ball cookie idea we meet our event
instead our McCain in their mascot
[Music]
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh guberniya a port rd
ghana our next story is about a young
woman who was bullied for her looks when
she was a kid but now she's a fashion
model every morning I would wake up and
say and some of them we were looking at
myself for hours and being like should I
go to now I should not go they're going
to be talking about your skin color and
it was not pretty you're not gradient
my name is could be a DF aka the mother
goddess a model and I am defying your
experiment I grew up in Senegal and then
I moved to Paris when I was 15 I was boy
like because of my skin color and I
stopped going school twice because of it
they were told me doc II thought of the
night and all kind of names I was going
to ashamed we died
I think skin watching is a huge deal
especially in African countries I have a
lot of colors I use skin bleaching
products since I was around 13 12 they
started selling me oh why don't you use
this why you want to be the star they
shall like being light is better than
being dark skinned like dark inner just
related as 430 when you look at film
open TVs or magazines the main villain
other that you're going to see is my
skin and I feel like other skin types
should be represented what I love about
my skin is how it connects me to
everybody when I go outside and the body
come to me to ask about where I'm from
there were a lot of people in the world
that would appreciate it that would be
like your scary story Yoona can do
your model and withering the negative
and positive comments a barrel more
positive comments I get a lot of
messages from a lot of women saying that
I inspire them a lot not just
dark-skinned girls but a lot of women
with insecurities my favorite part is
inspiring the youngest one because I
feel like when they grow up they can
pitch other given the view of beauty to
color change from day now we're going to
introduce you to a serious sneaker head
he's turned his love of kicks into a big
business and if you need I probably have
if I don't have it I can get it in 24
hours you're rapping if you have a video
shoot you need the shoes coming out in
two weeks I just have to make a call and
I'll get it for you
[Music]
every day millions of people tune - DJ
Khaled's snapshot the key to more
success to have a lot of pillows one of
my favorite DJ kala parents's is this
kid Ben how's business in a new year oh
I see you he's 16 years old and he's at
the helm of a burgeoning sneaker Empire
when he says it's done nearly a million
dollars in business and both clients
like DJ Cod and Chris Brown yes video
meet the sneaker dawn so my name is
Benjamin capitalistic people call me
Benjamin cakes but most you guys know me
as a sneaker done school ends at 3
o'clock I get home outlook for you
dinner do some homework and go straight
to the office space and like any good
Dom family is important I'm very I was
managing so if you need anything call me
okay not that family I'm the mother of
the sneaker Don to me he's my little boy
but I also see a business and he had a
goal he self driven he's motivated he's
a hard worker the great Don's they say
come from humble beginnings the first
person he's actually got me a game I was
in fifth grade the galaxy pack came out
and I got the LeBrons I love sneakers
after that probably around sixth grade
when my pens didn't want to fund my
sneaker hobby anymore I just figure out
a way how to get the money for it and
then I realized if I buy five or ten
pairs by paying people to stand in line
for me I could sell it to a larger
clients I'll make more money plus get my
shoe for free and then it just finally
broke through and money she started
coming in at first it amazed me how
sneakers can go for like so much money
for like one shoe people charging a
thousand I thought oh they could joke or
something I was in dollars but hey
that's why he's the sneaker dog so what
comes next
I'm really excited to open up a physical
store the first locations I mean to
Miami then I'm trying to LA New York and
Chicago all my friends when they dropped
out of me game they like it that it's
over there's no more like you're not get
on this and you're wasting your time
money not about what was true play
themselves indeed they did speaker down
indeed they did for our next story we're
going to head to a bank that's not about
money but about brains the Harvard brain
Bank is one of the largest brain banks
in the country at the moment we have
approximately 5,000 brain specimens my
name is Selena beretta I am the
scientific director of the Harvard brain
tissue resource center which we
affectionately call Harvard brain Bank
our mission is to collect brain
specimens store them characterize them
and then redistribute them out to
investigators across the world the do
research on the human brain and in
particular on large number of
neurological and psychiatric brain
disorders such as schizophrenia bipolar
disorder Parkinson's Huntington and many
others
The Brain Bank University we have two
sets of people that are on call 24/7 we
have a very limited time window from
when the person passes away to the time
we need to be done with this whole
processing so this is going to be you
first brain late at night right we have
to do it in less than 24 hours our
courier will bring it online hospital to
the brain bank so just put it out here
so we're going to take ourselves it
would be a dissection is ready to
dissect the brain
[Music]
that involves of separating the two and
fears one of the twenty Spears is put in
a solution that preserves it the other
hemisphere will be dissected in thick
sections and those will be frozen we are
not even close to understand a lot of
what we take for granted our thoughts
were instincts our feelings our emotions
there are a lot of questions we still
don't know and all of our brain
functions they will probably be studied
for a long time to come a brain donation
is in a very concrete way a gift of
knowledge and it cannot be done without
the help of families and people willing
to the native range thanks for joining
us and watching these four great big
stories click on the horse to subscribe
leave us comment below okay next time
catch you later